it may be far too soon to see past the
gloom but you can always enjoy the
sunshine plenty of people are out in
Brighton but most were keeping their
distance encouraged by the banners after
two weeks and lockdown now the
possibility it could go on for months
more here they were taking it in their
stride still get out and do bits that's
the important thing for me the longer we
don't cope with it the longer it's going
to be so we have to you know we just
have to stay indoors I'm pleased to see
now practically everybody are keeping
their distance he took some wild for
them to just take the aim is to keep
people at home or moving to exercise not
meeting in gatherings where the virus
can be passed around the police have
been out in numbers but are hoping
they've got the people on their side
enforcement is really the last option
they don't want to be enforcing yes our
whole policing style is about engaging
with the public that is our policing
model its policing by consent so that's
what we will be looking to see over this
weekend and really just asking the
public please be sensible we're doing
this together it's a collective endeavor
with BT as far as we need to stay home
we need to save lives and protect our
NHS key questions now is there an exit
strategy for the lockdown and what
happens next the scientific scramble for
a vaccine is underway 50 different
projects are pursuing one worldwide the
head of one of them told Sky News there
are reasons to be hopeful I'm optimistic
because there are so many vaccine
projects underway around the world and I
really see this as perhaps the the most
plausible solution as an exit strategy
from the pandemic and I hope that we
will have multiple successful players
and so that we cannot scale
manufacturing and be able to provide
doses around the world in the near
future but a vaccine for Matthew still
isn't likely for a year
thought finding effective treatments to
ease pressure on the NHS is also vital
as is the whole country sticking to the
lock down and keeping its distance
possibly for months to come Dominic
Waghorn sky knee is Brighton